[Música]
hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo nos
saluda juliet riaño
[Música]
la migración volvió al centro del debate
político en eeuu mientras el gobierno
demócrata disuade a los migrantes para
que no viajen al país el futuro de dos
medidas para evitar su llegada se
debaten en los tribunales hablamos de
quédate en mexico y el título 42 sobre
quédate en mexico la discusión está en
la corte suprema que escucha los
argumentos de quienes rechazan derogar
la este es un programa de línea dura
instaurado durante el mandato de donald
trump y que establece que los
solicitantes de asilo deben esperar la
respuesta a sus solicitudes de asilo en
mexico el presidente de byd en busca
eliminarla manuel acá no tiene los
detalles a continuación
dignidad para los migrantes era el
mensaje que reunía a un grupo de
defensores de derechos humanos frente a
la corte suprema de eeuu mientras al
interior del recinto los jueces
escuchaban los argumentos de los
fiscales de texas y misurí sobre la
política migratoria conocida como
quédate en méxico américa
creado en méxico fue horrible para
muchos de nuestros clientes tuvimos uno
que por ejemplo fue tomado como rehén o
apenas llegado a la casa blanca el
presidente joe biden buscó eliminar la
ley que había entrado en vigor durante
el mandato de suerte donald trump y que
obligaba a los solicitantes de asilo
esperar sus audiencias en mexico pero su
objetivo se truncó cuando las
autoridades de los estados de texas y
missouri presentaron una demanda para
mantener el programa tras el fallo de un
tribunal de primera instancia se
restableció a finales de diciembre del
año pasado
ahora el presidente busca un segundo
round en la corte suprema a pesar de la
férrea defensa de los fiscales que
argumentan que eeuu carece de centros de
detención en el avión y si yo veo a
misurí como un representante de todos
los demás estados que se ven afectados
por la crisis que tenemos en la frontera
además la pugna se centra en saber si el
programa puede ser usado a discreción lo
que permite que se le ponga fin tal y
como defiende la administración de haydn
así como argumentan los fiscales los
funcionarios estadounidenses pueden
regresar una persona cuya solicitud de
asilo está en estudio o fue week espero
que podamos comenzar a proteger al
pueblo estadounidense de las
consecuencias de este enorme vacío legal
que todos saben que es un vacío legal
que tiene consecuencias dramáticas para
la seguridad de nuestro país
de la decisión de la corte dependerá que
badén pueda darle un primer giro a la
política migratoria estadounidense un
paso que irá acompañado con su intento
de poner fin al título 42 y sobrado por
trump durante la emergencia sanitaria
permite expulsar a los migrantes que
vengan de un país con predominancia de
kobe 19 como ya lo decíamos también es
incierto el futuro del título 42 los
centros para el control y prevención de
enfermedades anunciaron su plan de
eliminar la norma en mayo pero ahora
líderes republicanos buscan frenar el
proyecto y un juez federal bloqueó
temporalmente su eventual eliminación
en el lado mexicano de la frontera con
eeuu los migrantes se esperan ansiosos
una fecha el 23 de mayo marcaría el fin
de una larga espera
ese día se levantaría el polémico título
42 una política fronteriza que permite
la deportación express y bloquea el
ingreso al país de personas consideradas
un riesgo por cuestiones sanitarias
una norma impulsada por el gobierno de
donald trump y creada bajo el argumento
de la pandemia
dos años después esa medida ha permitido
la expulsión de más de 17 millones de
migrantes y de concretarse quedan
algunos vacíos por resolver hasta el
aviso que se va a concluir el 23 de mayo
pero no ha dicho cómo los va a procesar
que eso va a ser el la gran duda de lo
que nos va a nosotros permitir tomar
acciones o estrategias en tijuana los
migrantes varados en refugios esperan
poder avanzar con sus solicitudes de
asilo después de meses de espera
estamos sufriendo aquí es increíble que
nadie esté observando y viviendo esto es
decir el sufrimiento de toda esta gente
en la frontera nadie
josé maría garcía fundó el movimiento
juventud 2000 un albergue que brinda
refugio a unas 120 familias en tiendas
de campaña más que una solución
momentánea espera una definitiva
esperemos que realmente los gobiernos de
todos los países del mundo a su trabajo
que les corresponde hacer para que su
comunidad no tenga que emigrar a otros
lugares que vayan viendo todas las
necesidades de su gente no para que esto
no suceda pareciera que fuera lo
contrario mariana y su esposo migraron
por la violencia en su país están en
tijuana nuevamente después de ser
deportados por eeuu a su natal honduras
la necesidad los obliga aún otros
lo que hemos sufrido bastante
más la vez que nos deportaron teníamos
caminando cuando saldos
[Música]
pero pese a lo vivido su deseo es llegar
a eeuu
el presidente joe biden pidió apoyo a
mexico para evitar una llegada masiva de
personas a la frontera sur
estadounidense precisamente cuando
faltan seis meses para las elecciones
legislativas y la migración vuelve a
perfilarse como uno de los temas de
debate
y el dato de migración de la semana más
de 3.000 migrantes murieron o
desaparecieron en su viaje hacia europa
por el mar en 2021 tres rutas dejan
estas cifras la del mediterráneo central
y occidental y la que de áfrica conduce
hacia las islas canarias por el
atlántico
hasta que inmigrantes de france 24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrantes f24
sigan con más información en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
[Música]